namo tassa bhagavatam arahatu samasambuddhasam namo tassa bhagavatam arahatu samasambuddhasam namo tassa bhagavatam
Hommage au Bouddha, le Noblesse, le Noblesse et le Noblesse parfaitement réveillé par lui-même.
J'ai pensé cette soirée de ramener ensemble quelques enseignements.
Ce soir, je pensais que j'allais regrouper un petit peu certains des enseignements en définissant le mot central des enseignements du Bouddha qui est dukkha.
Et ensuite, je voudrais parler d'une voie de libération à travers la générosité.
Dukkha, ça veut dire un endroit difficile à vivre.
Et le Bouddha a appris toutes ses enseignements à cette phrase, Dukkha Dukkha Nirodha.
Et le Bouddha a retiré tout son enseignement de cette phrase Dukkha, Dukkha Nirodha.
Qui est aussi élégant que E égale M6.
Dukkha est traduit comme souffrance.
On a toujours traduit duka par le mot souffrance.
Mais en fait c'était un peu trop fort ce mot.
Parce qu'on n'est pas toujours dans la souffrance.
Ensuite on l'a traduit par insatisfaction.
Qui n'est pas trop mal comme mot.
À mon humble opinion bien sûr.
D'autres enseignants l'utilisent de différentes façons.
Une est le mot stress.
Mais le Bouddha parle de trois types de dukkha.
Le premier est dukkha dukkha.
Ce qui signifie la souffrance ou l'insatisfaction
Donc c'est la souffrance qui vient de l'insatisfaction de vivre dans un lieu, dans un monde dur, difficile.
Oui, l'insatisfaction de vivre.
Excusez-moi.
Donc il y a un autre dukkha, Deepri Manadukka, qui vient d'une souffrance qui vient de l'impermanence.
Et puis il y a Sankatadukkha, qui est la souffrance qui vient des choses composées.
Donc le premier est quelque chose que nous avons particulièrement investigué dans le Vipassana.
En général, ça se réfère à un inconfort que l'on ressent ou bien une forme de souffrance.
Maintenant, à chaque moment ou dans chaque processus, il y a toujours une donnée
Dans tous les processus, il y a toujours quelque chose qui est donné, qui est un fait de base.
C'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas éviter.
C'est quelque chose qui est conditionné.
Par exemple, si vous stubbez votre dos et que vous avez de la douleur dans le dos, c'est tout.
Vous ne pouvez pas...
Par exemple, vous cognez votre orteil contre quelque chose, vous avez mal à l'orteil et c'est normal, il n'y a pas grand-chose à y faire.
Quand ces émotions viennent de notre cœur, on peut faire quelque chose.
On ne peut pas.
Quand ça vient du cœur, on ne peut rien faire non plus.
Ce sont des souffrances qui apparaissent, qu'on le veuille ou pas.
Il nous est certainement arrivé à tous de se réveiller le matin avec le sentiment que non, on ne devrait pas se réveiller finalement.
Il y a aussi des gens qui...
Il y a aussi des gens qui, sans le vouloir, simplement, ils nous énervent.
C'est comme ça.
Ce n'est pas eux qui produisent l'irritation.
C'est juste parce qu'on ne les aime pas.
Ou on n'aime pas la façon dont ils se comportent, où ils sont.
Donc, ce dukkha réfère à tout ce que nous expérimentons, qui est soit
Ce tout cas se réfère à tout ce que nous estimons être désagréable.
Il faut ajouter à cela les conséquences de la complaisance.
Il ne faut pas oublier que l'attachement, ça veut dire qu'on est dépendant de quelque chose d'extérieur à nous pour notre état intérieur de bonheur.
Il faut être très clair à ce sujet.
Le cœur répond avec bonheur à une certaine situation donnée.
Et c'est conditionné.
Donc...
Par exemple, quand on est descendu et qu'on a vu la salle de biscuits, le cœur était naturellement enchanté.
Mais comme nous pratiquons tous le renoncement, nous avons laissé les biscuits sur l'assiette.
Donc n'oublions pas que cette sorte de conditionnement a des conséquences.
Nous aurions par exemple été très déçus s'il n'y avait pas eu de biscuits.
nous aurions été irrités contre Victor et Marie-Claude nous aurions contacté Anne-Michel et nous aurions parlé de nos peurs et de nos angoisses face à cette situation et bien sûr nous aurions dû souffrir des conséquences d'une addiction qui n'était pas satisfaite
et nous aurions dû souffrir les conséquences d'une addiction qui n'a pas été satisfaite et de l'autre côté quand on mange trop de gâteaux ou quand on a une longue retraite et que tous les jours jour après jour on a des mêmes biscuits mais comme à Satipanya c'est toujours les mêmes gâteaux
Ça devient très barbant.
Les gens se plaignent.
Toutes ces conséquences dépendent du fait qu'on est attaché au départ à quelque chose.
Quand elles arrivent, quand elles font surface,
Toutes ces formes d'insatisfaction ne sont pas vraiment de la souffrance.
Ce sont le dukkha qui est là, qui est une base, qui est donnée.
Ce n'est pas encore ça la souffrance.
N'oubliez pas qu'il y a cette réaction.
Et la réaction est d'enlever ou d'exprimer et d'enlever notre chest.
Et la réaction, c'est soit d'éloigner cette insatisfaction, soit de l'exprimer pour s'en débarrasser.
Et dans les deux cas, nous ajoutons de la souffrance à cette souffrance originale.
donc ce que nous avons appris c'est que si nous ne mettons pas l'accent là-dessus ce deuxième état d'insatisfaction lui peut disparaître donc il y a un point où la souffrance donnée et la réaction ne sont pas l'actuel second dukkha
Il y a un point où ni la satisfaction de base, ni la satisfaction née de notre réaction, ni le véritable dukkha.
On parle de dukkha dukkha.
Alors on essaie de savoir ce qu'est le deuxième dukkha.
Le deuxième dukkha est quand vous vous identifiez avec la réaction.
Le deuxième ducat, c'est quand on s'identifie à notre réaction.
Mais à l'intérieur de notre cœur, il y a toujours ce sentiment d'insatisfaction.
Maintenant, parce que nous n'avons pas indulgé dans cette réaction, la réaction commence à mourir.
Mais si on ne se complaît pas dans cette réaction, cette réaction disparaît peu à peu.
Et si on continue à ne pas s'identifier à nos réactions, cette habitude de réagir va disparaître elle aussi.
Mais il y a toujours le dukkha de base.
C'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas éviter, c'est dans la vie, il y a des occasions où il y a de la souffrance, de la douleur.
On ne peut rien y faire, c'est le fait qu'on est un être humain.
La pire souffrance, bien sûr, pour nous, c'est la mort.
La pire des souffrances pour nous, bien sûr, c'est la mort.
Alors, quelle est notre réaction quand quelqu'un nous dit qu'on lui a dit qu'il n'avait plus que quelques mois à vivre ?
Au départ, il y a un choc.
Imaginez si c'est à vous qu'on disait ça.
Je serais choqué.
Moi, je serais choqué.
Je ne suis pas prêt à mourir à aucun moment.
Donc, ce choc, en fait, c'est la peur des conséquences de cette révélation.
Et ça, c'est lié au degré d'attachement que nous avons à notre corps.
Donc il y a différentes étapes.
qui ont été bien expliquées par Elisabeth Kübler-Rose, qui s'est occupée des personnes en fin de vie.
Le deuxième, c'est marchander.
On essaie de marchander avec la maladie,
en espérant peut-être que les médicaments vont vous guérir.
Ou bien vous allez voir un maître de méditation, vous lui demandez de vous guérir.
Ou bien vous allez faire du Reiki.
Ou bien vous êtes déterminé à manger des milliers de vitamines D.
Vous prenez la détermination de manger des kilos, des kilos de vitamine D.
On essaie de trouver un moyen de tourner autour du problème.
Parfois on a même recours à la magie.
Mais quand on vous dit que finalement le cancer empire, la réaction c'est la colère.
Et la colère est là parce qu'on sait qu'on ne peut pas se battre contre la maladie.
Et à ce moment-là arrive la dépression.
Et quand on s'habitue peu à peu à la situation, on l'accepte, finalement on arrive à l'équanimité.
Et c'est là que les personnes peuvent mourir en paix.
Dans le processus de renaissance, votre dernier état d'esprit a un effet très important sur votre future vie.
Donc imaginez si vous mouriez en plein choc.
Ou dans une sorte de
Ou dans un état de pensée complètement erroné.
Ou bien dans la colère ou dans la dépression.
Dans le bouddhisme, on dit que toutes ces choses-là ont un effet à long terme.
Il y avait un homme qui venait à notre centre à Birmingham.
C'était un homme qui était en dépression et qui avait déjà fait plusieurs tentatives de suicide.
Il avait même une corde dans le coffre de sa voiture.
Assez désespéré.
Et donc il avait pris l'habitude d'aller dans un centre bouddhiste au Pays de Galles où à chaque fois qu'il était déprimé, on lui remontait le moral et on l'empêchait de faire une nouvelle tentative de suicide.
Un jour, il s'est retrouvé là-bas, mais il n'y avait personne.
Et on l'a trouvé pendu dans la grange.
Alors, j'ai demandé à mon maître quelles sont les conséquences
Pour une personne qui se suicide pour des raisons pas très justes.
Pendant encore cent vies, ils vont continuer à se pendre.
Et je me suis dit...
Et puis j'ai réfléchi.
Se tuer, c'est un acte vraiment purposeful, déterminé.
Il faut avoir une force de volonté pour se tuer, non ?
Et en particulier en se pendant.
Parce que ça prend du temps.
Je veux dire, si vous vous mettez sur un cliff, au moins vous obtenez le délire de tomber dans l'air pendant un moment.
Donc j'ai pensé à moi-même,
Donc je me suis dit, c'est vraiment dans la conscience de la personne.
Et il voit cela comme un échappatoire à la souffrance.
Donc on peut comprendre que, comme un profond conditionnement dans cette personne, dans la prochaine vie, si il se trouve dans des situations similaires, ce désir va remonter.
Donc c'est vrai qu'on peut se dire que si la situation était si profondément ancrée en lui, ce désespoir, il est fort possible que dans une autre vie ce désir apparaisse à nouveau.
Que vous croyez aux vies futures ou pas, ça arrive aussi dans cette vie.
Même à l'âge de deux, nous avons fait des décisions que nous suivons toujours.
Il semblerait que même à l'âge de deux ans, nous formons des décisions que nous continuons encore aujourd'hui à suivre.
C'est vers l'âge de deux ou trois ans que nous décidons que le monde, c'est moi.
et donc apparemment dès l'âge de 2-3 ans on a pris cette décision très profonde et très ancrée que je vais faire en sorte que la vie me serve à moi si ça c'est en dessous en sous-jacent de notre psychologie et que nous n'en sommes pas conscients vous pouvez voir que
À partir de là, à chaque fois qu'on se cogne contre un mur ou que n'importe quoi de négatif nous arrive, on ne comprendra pas pourquoi.
Et c'est toujours eux.
Ils sont le problème.
Par exemple, les personnes qui se marient, qui divorcent, marient, divorcent, marient, divorcent, à chaque fois le problème ce n'est pas eux, c'est l'autre qui a un problème.
Donc si on ne prend pas conscience qu'il y a une certaine forme de souffrance qui est comme ça, qui est donnée au départ,
on va croire, on va se faire piéger par toutes les autres occasions de souffrance qui vont nous arriver.
Donc, ce que fait notre méditation, c'est qu'elle nous met en évidence l'apparition du problème originel.
Pour voir comment nous nous relions à lui.
Ah !
Et sans que nous nous identifions à aucune des deux formes de dukkha.
Et petit à petit, ces choses-là disparaissent.
En tout cas, elles ne prennent pas trop de force sur nous, d'emprise sur nous.
Ça, c'était dukkha dukkha.
Ensuite, il y a la souffrance de l'impermanence.
Et là, il s'agit de la souffrance qui naît des plaisirs et des joies de la vie.
Parce que, juste comme nous prenons quelque chose que nous voulons finalement,
parce que dès que nous nous saisissons de quelque chose que nous voulions et que nous avons enfin la situation commence à faire que les choses nous échappent ça peut être quelque chose sur le long terme par exemple vous donnez tout ce que vous avez dans un travail et puis finalement un jour on vous met à la porte ou bien comme le bon repas que nous avons eu aujourd'hui
Et puis tout d'un coup l'assiette est vide.
Cette histoire d'impermanence, ça va aussi très profond.
C'est lié au fait que notre vie a une qualité de momentané.
Et ça nous amène à ce niveau existentiel.
Parce que le changement c'est quelque chose de très agréable jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans.
Mais après ça dégringole.
Et toute cette dégringolade vers la vieillesse, ce n'est pas quelque chose d'agréable.
Ça, ça fait partie aussi de notre impermanence.
Et bien sûr, la mort met un point final à tout ce processus.
Donc, il y a pas mal de souffrance dans le fait de vieillir.
Surtout quand vous vieillissez, que vous jetez un regard en arrière sur l'époque où vous étiez heureux.
Cette nostalgie du passé.
Ah, si seulement !
Toute cette souffrance nous arrive du fait de l'impermanence.
Et le dernier, c'est le dukkha qui est lié au fait que la nature est composée.
Nous tendons à voir les choses comme
Nous avons tendance à voir les choses comme si elles faisaient un tout.
Par exemple, quand on regarde un arbre, par exemple le bel arbre tout jaune, la quête dehors, on a tendance à voir l'ensemble de l'arbre.
Quand on voit un voiture passer sur la rue, on a tendance à voir juste le voiture.
Quand on voit une voiture passer sur la route, on voit la voiture comme un concept visuel.
Quand on voit les gens, on les voit comme des personnes.
Et ceci nous cache le fait qu'en réalité tout est fait de petites parties.
La science nous dit qu'on peut descendre vraiment jusqu'à un niveau très très petit d'énergie.
Mais ce n'est pas à ce niveau-là que nous vivons en temps normal.
Et donc, quand nous tournons les choses dans un trou, nous
Quand on croit que les choses font un tout, nous leur donnons une réalité, une substance.
Une des expériences que j'ai eues qui a apporté ce sens de composé d'un être humain,
J'ai eu une fois une expérience qui m'a vraiment fait comprendre ce que ça voulait dire que les êtres humains étaient composés.
Je suis allé dans un endroit à l'hôpital où ils faisaient une autopsie.
En Thaïlande, en Birmanie, des endroits comme ça, on laisse les moines entrer dans les endroits où on fait les autopsies.
Pas pour se débarrasser de vous.
Mais pour pratiquer la contemplation de la mort.
Dans le discours sur comment établir l'awareness,
dans le discours qu'a fait le Bouddha sur les fondements de l'attention il y a toute une section très longue sur les différentes étapes du cadavre qui se décompose parce qu'à cette époque on laissait souvent les corps comme ça en plein air pour que les animaux les mangent
ou bien pour qu'ils se décomposent de manière naturelle.
Et les commentaires nous donnent des conseils pour si jamais on voulait faire la même chose.
Quand vous voyez un corps mort, comme certains d'entre vous l'ont, et quand vous sentez un corps mort, c'est une expérience très différente du contact avec un être humain vivant.
Vous réalisez que tout ce qui créait cette personne est complètement perdu.
Et là, on prend conscience vraiment que ce qui faisait que ce corps était une personne, ça, ça a disparu définitivement.
Et c'est l'occasion de voir que le corps est fait de différentes choses.
Et si on ne le met pas à l'esprit constamment, alors quand quelque chose nous arrive, ou à quelqu'un que nous aimons,
Mais si nous n'avons pas cette conscience en permanence en nous, quand quelque chose nous arrive ou quand ça arrive à quelqu'un d'autre, c'est un choc.
Le Bouddha a dit aussi qu'il y avait trois types de désirs qui, en un sens, matchent.
qui correspondent d'une certaine manière à ces trois types de souffrances.
C'est la réaction.
Le premier, c'est le désir de s'emparer et de garder les choses qui nous sont agréables.
Le deuxième, c'est de
ont le désir de continuer à vivre.
Cela pourrait aussi signifier le désir de maintenir ce que nous avons qui est beau et agréable.
Donc ce désir de continuer, le désir de devenir, est profond dans nous.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le désir de devenir ou le désir de continuer et c'est quelque chose qui est très profondément ancré en nous.
Mais le Bouddha dit qu'il y a aussi un désir d'annihilation.
Dans la vie ordinaire, ce désir, ça signifie se débarrasser, vouloir se débarrasser au plus vite de tout ce qui nous dérange, qui nous déplait.
À un niveau plus profond, c'est se débarrasser de notre moi.
De manière la plus évidente, c'est se suicider.
Mais aussi, rappelez-vous, c'est à ces moments-là
Mais c'est aussi, quand on se force à s'endormir, c'est aussi une forme de ne pas exister.
C'est une forme de se débarrasser de soi.
Quand je suis fatigué, quand j'en ai ras le bol de tout, je m'allonge et puis j'oublie tout.
Je disparais du monde, d'une certaine manière.
C'est vrai que dans l'oubli, il n'y a pas de souffrance.
Mais c'est un faux refuge.
Parce qu'un jour ou l'autre, on va se réveiller.
Donc, là, vous avez ce match.
Le Bouddha nous dit qu'il y a
Donc là on a les deux correspondances, d'un côté on a trois types d'insatisfaction.
Celui qui est basé sur n'importe tout ce qui peut être insatisfaisant.
Juste la qualité, la seconde one is that quality of impermanence which stops us holding on to what we love.
La deuxième, c'est cette qualité qui fait que tout est impermanent, qui nous empêche de retenir ce que nous aimons.
Et la troisième, c'est l'impression que tout est substantiel, tout fait un tout, et être choqué quand on s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas le cas.
Et cela va correspondre aux trois types de désirs.
Le désir de vouloir continuer à avoir du plaisir.
Le désir de devenir, de continuer à être une personne.
Le désir de se débarrasser de tout, y compris de nous-mêmes.
De tout ce qu'on n'aime pas, y compris de nous-mêmes.
Donc maintenant...
En ayant compris, devons-nous dire, le côté sombre, il y a bien sûr un côté lumineux.
Donc l'autre côté, bien sûr, c'est de développer tout ce qui est beau en nous.
Et quand le Bouddha a donné un discours aux gens de l'âge, il a toujours commencé avec la générosité.
Et quand le Bouddha donnait un enseignement aux gens, il commençait toujours en parlant de la générosité.
Il disait que même un voleur pouvait être généreux.
Comme Robin Hood.
Donc, la générosité, quand vous êtes généreux avec vos choses, ou avec votre richesse, ou avec votre temps, vous donnez quelque chose.
Quand vous êtes généreux avec votre argent, vos objets, les objets qui vous appartiennent, ou avec votre temps, vous êtes en train d'abandonner quelque chose qui est à vous.
Et cet abandon, c'est le renoncement.
Par exemple, vous donnez de l'argent à une association
Et cet argent, vous auriez pu l'utiliser pour vous faire plaisir à vous-même.
Peut-être que vous allez donner quelque chose qui est facile pour vous à donner.
C'est une petite générosité.
Mais si vous pratiquez la prononciation, vous donnez quelque chose qui vous fait un peu mal.
Si vous pratiquez le renoncement, vous donnez quelque chose qui vous fait quand même un petit pincement au cœur quand vous le donnez.
Là, vous avez vraiment le sentiment d'abandonner quelque chose.
Pareil avec son temps.
Offrir votre temps pour aider quelqu'un, vous pouvez le faire sans intérêt.
Il peut être, devons-nous dire,
Quand vous donnez du temps pour aider quelqu'un, par exemple, ça peut être quelque chose que vous faites avec intérêt, que vous trouvez agréable.
Mais c'est quand vous donnez du temps pour faire des choses qu'en fait vous aimeriez bien
Garder ce temps pour faire des choses pour vous-même, à ce moment-là, c'est vraiment plus un acte de renoncement.
Il faut être très clair qu'il y a d'un côté la générosité et d'un autre côté un marchandage, donnant-donnant.
Ah !
Imaginez qu'un ami vous dise ce week-end je vais faire de la décoration, ce serait sympa que tu viennes m'aider.
Il ne s'agit pas d'une grande charité comme la croix rouge, ni rien du tout, juste aider un ami.
So, you say, yes, yes, I'll come along Saturday.
Ok, je viendrai samedi.
And then, when you get back home, you think, why did I do that?
Et quand vous rentrez chez vous, vous vous dites, mais pourquoi j'ai accepté de faire ça?
And so, come Saturday morning, you ring and tell them you have a very severe headache.
Et le samedi matin, vous téléphonez et vous dites que vous avez une grave mal de tête.
D'un autre côté, vous dites non, quand même, je me suis engagée, je vais le faire.
Et au moins, vous ne souffrez pas de la culpabilité de ne pas avoir suivi vos commitments.
Et au moins là, vous n'aurez pas à subir la culpabilité, le désagrément de la culpabilité de ne pas avoir fait ce que vous aviez promis de faire.
Donc vous passez une bonne journée, vous décorez.
Et puis quelques mois plus tard, tout d'un coup, il y a beaucoup de mauvaises herbes dans votre jardin.
Vous téléphonez votre ami et vous lui dites, j'ai beaucoup de mauvaises herbes dans mon jardin.
Et votre ami vous dit, je ne sais pas du tout faire le jardinage, je n'aime pas ça non plus.
Et vous vous dites, c'est la dernière fois que je vais décorer mon jardin.
Et vous, vous vous dites, c'est la dernière fois que je l'aiderai à décorer.
Dans ce sens-là, le fait que vous ayez aidé à la décoration, ce n'était pas un acte de charité.
C'était un donnant-donnant.
Je t'ai donné ça et j'attends que toi aussi tu me rendes l'appareil.
C'est pareil avec l'argent.
L'autre grosse erreur qu'on fait, c'est les gens qui veulent faire du bien, qui veulent être gentils avec les autres.
Ce genre de personnes, ils vous font du bien, mais le genre de bien qu'eux veulent vous faire.
Par exemple, votre ami est tombé malade.
Et vous pensez, oh, je vais lui apporter de la soupe.
Une soupe pleine de produits qui vont l'énergiser, du gingembre, toutes sortes de bonnes choses.
Et quand vous allez voir
et vous allez le voir, vous dire, regarde, j'ai apporté cette bonne soupe, elle fait du bien, elle va te donner de la vitalité.
Votre ami goûte cette soupe et vous dites à vous-même,
C'est ok.
Tu dis, ok, ne t'inquiète pas, je l'aurai.
Donc vous dites, à l'intérieur de vous-même, vous dites, ok, c'est la dernière fois que je lui apporte quoi que ce soit, mais à l'extérieur, vous dites, ok, c'est pas grave, c'est moi qui la boirai.
Et à ce moment-là, votre ami vous dit, par contre, et vous dites, oh !
Par contre, il y a quelque chose que tu pourrais faire pour moi.
Et vous dites, ah bon ?
Est-ce que tu pourrais nettoyer les toilettes pour moi ?
Vous savez que vous faites cette pratique de celui qui veut se faire plaisir à lui-même quand vous êtes déçu de la réaction de l'autre.
Vous êtes déçu.
Donc, comment allez-vous dépasser ce problème ?
Alors, comment dépasser ce problème ?
On commence par leur demander ce dont ils ont besoin, tout simplement.
Et après, vous pouvez décider si vous voulez le faire ou pas.
Donc, l'acte de charité n'est pas aussi simple qu'on pourrait le croire.
Maintenant, notre...
Ce sentiment de générosité grandit quand on se rend compte à quel point on pourrait avoir la gratitude pour les choses.
Pensez à tout ce que vous avez reçu dans la vie et que vous ne pouvez pas rendre.
Déjà votre vie.
Le Bouddha a dit que même si vous passiez votre vie à porter votre père et votre mère sur chacune de vos épaules, vous n'auriez pas encore rendu toute la dette que vous leur devez pour vous avoir donné la vie.
Et toutes les choses que la société nous a donné, l'éducation, la santé et tout ça,
Et tout ce que la société nous a donné, l'éducation, la santé, etc.
Tout ça, c'est de l'argent qui est venu de l'argent de tout le monde, en fait.
Si vous faites une liste de toutes ces choses que vous avez reçues, que vous ne pouvez pas rendre, on ne les rendra pas.
Ah, et puis, bien sûr, ça vous apporte ce désir, au moins, de faire ce que vous pouvez.
Et ça, ça peut faire grandir en vous le désir de faire tout ce que vous pouvez pour les autres.
Et là, on est dans un cercle vertueux.
C'est par gratitude que le désir d'être généreux arrive.
Et cette générosité peut être avec notre argent ou avec notre temps.
Et quand nous sommes généreux,
Et quand on est généreux, on doit renoncer à quelque chose qui aurait pu nous être utile.
Et plus on renonce, plus on défait ce sentiment d'égoïsme de moi.
Nous sommes en train de miner par-dessous la structure du moi.
En fait, le moi, c'est un concept qui est dans la tête, c'est une notion.
C'est quelque chose qui se manifeste dans notre relation au monde.
C'est pourquoi la enseignement du Bouddha est
C'est pour ça que dans la vie quotidienne, le Bouddha nous parle toujours d'éthique.
La distinction qu'on peut faire entre la psychothérapie dont on parlait hier soir et l'enseignement du Bouddha, c'est que la psychothérapie tente de médicaliser nos problèmes.
Tandis que la psychothérapie a tendance à médicaliser nos problèmes.
Tandis que le Bouddha dirait que l'origine est morale et donc il apporterait comme médicament l'éthique.
Donc il faut qu'il y ait un processus de purification en nous.
Plus on est pur,
plus nous sommes purs à l'intérieur, plus nous voyons les choses clairement.
Parce que toutes ces visions erronées qui bloquent notre vision juste, elles sont minées.
Et ces delusions, rappelez-vous, sont toujours grâce à ces trois caractéristiques.
Et cette vision erronée, c'est toujours par les trois caractéristiques qu'on peut les toucher.
C'est comme ça que ce cercle vertueux va petit à petit nous amener à la fin de la souffrance.
Avec cette bonne nouvelle, je peux seulement espérer que mes mots ont été d'aide.
J'espère que mes paroles ont été utiles.
Que je n'ai pas causé davantage de confusion.
Par votre engagement dans la vie telle que le Bouddha l'a décrite, puissiez-vous être libéré de toute souffrance.
De préférence bientôt plutôt que tard.